whereas to translate and dilate the unit
circle to map it onto each circle so
this is the unit circle right over here
it's centered at zero comma zero it has
a radius of one that's why we call it a
unit circle and when they say translate
they say move it around so that would be
a translation of it and then dilating it
means making it larger so dilating that
unit circle would be doing whoops i just
translated it would be doing something
like that so we're going to transit and
dilate this unit circle to map it onto
each circle so for example i can
translate it so that the center is
translated to the center of that magenta
circle and then i can dilate it so that
it has been mapped onto that larger
magenta circle i can do that let me do
it for a few more i'm not going to do it
for all of them just to just give you
the idea of what they're talking about
so now i'm translating the center of my
it's no longer a unit circle i'm
translating the center of my circle to
the center of the purple circle and now
i'm going to dilate it so it has the
same radius and notice i can map it and
so if you can map one
shape to another through translation and
dilation then the things are by
definition they are going to be similar
so this is really just an exercise and
seeing that all circles are similar if
you just take any circle and you make it
have the same center as another circle
then you can just scale it
you can just scale it up or down to
match the circle that you moved it to
the center of so there you have it
hopefully this gives you a sense that
all circles are similar